we are back and Michael Hayden does the
effectiveness of drones outweigh the
moral concerns about them good question
I meant to get that too great it's a
great question and there's always a
trade-off and even if the first-order
effect is what you want and you achieve
it you always create second third and
fourth order effects that you're going
to have to pay a tariff on sooner or
later so you don't do it lightly the
line I use with regard to drones and our
current circumstances we don't need a
switch we need to die
meaning when meaning that there's still
times when such an activity is necessary
when we've got an adversary wants to
come in over the perimeter wire and kill
you me our families when you have a host
government unwilling and/or unable to
act you need to keep this tool available
but again it can't always be the default
option because you have to live them
with second and third I read your
article about it you said it's greatly
exaggerated how many civilian it is but
Derek also says it's necessary precise
and imperfect so yeah I always have to
live with them but again the alternative
you know if you look at us in Iraq
ten years ago kicking down doors actual
soldiers on the ground getting killed
and killing a lot of other Iraqis I
don't know if that's better but I also
think drones probably do create a lot of
terrorists yeah it said trade offs let
me give you a thought you know it's kind
of viewed as the antiseptic it's a video
game it's not really warfare we affirm
the from our side the people who operate
them in tremendous emotional strain
because they actually become intimately
familiar with the target with the pred
the reaper over a target do hours if not
days you see the family you see the
interaction you see this is a human
being and if that's still the target you
know it kisses the kids he kisses the
wife he gets in the SUV and it gets 400
yards away from the compound where you
can now take your first shot consistent
with the laws of armed conflict and you
do even though you've established this
great emotional bond so it's not a free
ride for the people tactically it is
however very alluring at the political
level because it allows you to do
and be seen as doing something without
embracing right the political risk of
putting Americans in harm's way uh
friendly Brits what explains your
antipathy toward the Clintons yeah you
know like the Clintons know am I alone
in this no no no I mean I think
everybody else has no I mean it's
feelings as mine aren't that mixed but
right uh-huh well you know I believe
that you can only really judge your
contemporaries you know people younger
and older than you you were kind of
guessing but with your contemporaries
you can really read them and Bill
Clinton was the first person to my
generation he's older but still my
generation to be the president running
for the president and the second I saw
him I thought I know this guy would I
school with him you know I didn't like
and then I don't like him now so I think
my anticipate is that I understand him
you know um I don't like them I to me he
seemed like a Republican you know I
didn't like his policies when he signed
that welfare bill I went insane you know
I mean he was way to the right of me a
lot of his success was about moving the
Democratic Party the right was a
successful moderate Republican president
right but I'm a liberal Democrat so that
is why I didn't like him
um Hillary Clinton the same really you
know Chelsea Clinton is just I throw in
to the mix you know it's not her fault
but right but she's not helping yes not
every situation but I'm voting for
Hillary Clinton and I want her to be the
president because it doesn't matter if
you like them you're not gonna have
dinner with him Michael Eric Dyson how
would you grade Obama as a quote black
president not even sure as opposed to
thee I am not sure what the other Obama
you know the other thee are they um look
I think he's gonna go down as one of the
most incredibly successful and
consequential presidents in the history
of this nation
what what who Israel what but what he
has done on race will not win him those
plaudits he is the Shaquille O'Neal of
presidents he he's got four rings he's
an incredibly great president but he
couldn't shoot free-throws it does no
good for us to pretend that your fellow
Neel could shoot a free-throw and in
fact because of that vulnerability they
came up with a heck of Shaq and they
exploited him at the end of the game
Obama's weakness his hack-a-shaq is race
because he was hesitant he
procrastinated and he was loath to
address an issue that ultimately forced
him into his bully pulpit with
extraordinary eloquence and the last
time I was on the show when he spoke
that eulogy at that church he was at his
best when he was at his blackest and
therefore he showed America something
more powerful so as at a president in
general and a as a president who dealt
with issues that are germane to African
American people about a seat but you you
choose as your analogy the NBA ranks
black dominated sport my sister
Jack Jews let's start fighting racism
back there it is most prevalent Mark
Ruffalo did you lot did your lobbying of
British Prime Minister David Cameron
have an effect on his fracking agenda uh
that remains to be seen
uh are you lobbied him I did I made a
video imploring him to think about the
health consequences and he entered you
uh no but that was before your analyst
for million days now you'll get the now
the land yeah now after tonight yeah Hey
look I'm waiting for that I'm waiting
but the four million people saw that it
was probably one of the most popular
posts that I've ever ever made it is a
long and I mean what he's doing there is
he's basically he told the people if you
don't want fracking we won't bring it
here
and recently he just turned that around
people said we don't want fracking and
he said well we're gonna force you to
take it and uh uh just yeah you know
James [ __ ] everywhere it was fracking
Hey lots of women other than the
business right like are there other
people that there nothing I don't know
like coming out frack my backyard right
well that made that come in they offer
your money for your farm then they turn
the water and in person the flames they
see that I've seen it I know make me
that's a good trade-off mmm know
something people don't think ahead you
know and some people were struggling
it's like somebody comes in and all good
money for your farm in a your farming
yeah failing anyway and you can I think
that's what it was well Obama be able to
finally close Guantanamo Bay yes that
was news this week we should have
mentioned it didn't have time for that
what do you think about that Guantanamo
Bay if it closes I hope he's able to do
it without creating a constitutional
crisis by closing it in the face of
congressional opposition that we
actually get to a political agreement
I'm not concerned about keeping
prisoners in the United States guys
you've talked to her we're really good
at that okay we can get on a very lucky
people here I am concerned I am
concerned about about the legal regime
that would be created by what the
president still agrees will be forever
prisoners there are some who will be
brought here who would not be tried and
whom we will not release and then signed
together the other factor is back to
your NBA metaphor oh don't don't up
right on the shot clock here all right
all right you need to be very careful
about who you shove off the door the
recidivism rate here is about 30%
truth-in-lending Bush administration
push more people out the door than this
administration all right so we both at
our comely old door well we did watch
most of the people who were there never
should have been there in the first
place and and we've kept people there
who even our own government says we
should release they're just rotting why
don't we give them a trial I still don't
understand like a second file system and
trials work we have never ever had a try
profile terrorists trial in a federal
court where there wasn't a conviction
they're pitching a perfect game you're
like you're like that's that's terrorist
bait I mean it's literally a terrorist
Manuel America doesn't try people they
say they don't but they don't right why
I turn my head yeah
yeah because this president and his
predecessor in the American Congress
have said we are war with al-qaeda that
gives us a variety of legal regimes not
a lawful regime and an unlawful regime
but a variety of legal regimes with
which to conduct the war one is
according to United States criminal law
another perfectly legal effort is to do
it under the laws of armed conflict a
president who is willing to kill people
outside of internationally agreed
theaters of conflict has already hugged
dearly the concept that we are at war
and therefore we do have a right as a
belligerent to keep members of the
opposing armed enemy force as prisoners
but we don't have to know and we that's
trial in the federal courthouse in New
York you know why didn't want the trial
they're bad for real-estate values that
is absolutely why playroom yes there
have been many trials there yes there
have been many trials and they're all
successful and so good but it reduces
America's moral authority all around the
world and you can see America trying to
lecture countries on democracy and the
importance of it and then this is what
we do it's just the optics suck yeah
really optics are not good okay although
given that inclination toward mass
incarceration one of the embarrassing
consequences though unintended could be
that hey Tara's got a fairer trial than
some of our American citizens you know
there's a reason why Isis execute people
in those orange like that like well that
color
exactly oh that's that exactly that you
know that color jumpsuit they put them
in that outfit because they want to
remind people of Gitmo I know can I just
look forward we're looking backwards and
I understand the impact right but
looking forward if you're unwilling to
use all the tools available look at the
dilemma then the book tries to emphasize
nothing easy and there's always
trade-offs sorry looking forward right
we don't capture anyone whom we cannot
when we don't have confidence this is
looking forward that we don't have
confidence we can bring into an article
3 court and we have a chain of evidence
and all those other things that are
required for a very high standard of
beyond reasonable doubt proof and when
we don't have that tool when we don't
have that body of proof when we don't
think we can bring them in to a federal
court instead of capturing under them
under the laws of armed conflict we kill
them hmm right what cantana mo was
filled with people that they just
perhaps I mean we hear the story again
that they were we wait a minute night
right yeah we're just they were just
part of a tangled in Afghanistan right
wrong dude 15 years it's on one guy
sorry we just need to close gun quantum
obey yeah and stop it's just a political
issue for politicians to be able to say
I won't allow them on American soil I
can't say these guys have seen Conair
too many times they think these are
master criminals that are just sad old
men right okay Joanna Coles do you see
gun control as a woman's issue well you
see that control as a woman's well the
boyfriend loophole is very worrying well
you know though there is a sort of
boyfriend loophole so actually single
women are not as well protected as
married women and women with children
and that's to do with when if a man has
been violent in a relationship um and
you you're and he's no longer living
with the woman and you're dating him he
can still buy a gun if he
is been violent in a relationship and
he's still with the woman he's not
allowed to buy a gun with background
checks so actually single women are more
vulnerable and it's incredibly important
actually for single women to a know that
they're more likely to be murdered by a
guy with a gun than if you're married to
him and secondly that you should have a
conversation with someone if you're
dating them about do you have a gun
where do you keep it where's the
ammunition and don't have it when you're
both I know have it when you're saying
liberals hate having that that you know
sort of gives ammunition yeah until the
pro-gun people but the truth is that men
are generally stronger than women and
you know a gun is an equalizer well I
need a woman's holding the gun yeah yeah
yeah but a woman can hold a gun it's not
too heavy for her to pick up okay
well except that if you live in a
household with a gun one of you is more
likely to die from gun death or from
violent death and if you don't have
you're better off not having some
measure of not having a gun you know if
he's in the bushes and I was a woman I'd
like to have a gun I would because if he
gets in the house then I don't have any
recourse
well statistics show that you're much
less likely to be harmed by a gun if
there are no guns around mm yeah I think
yeah that's a lot of idiots who don't
know what they're doing with a gun you
know uh
does Chris Christie backing Trump lend
him any credibility with the Republican
establishment which one Trump or
Christie that's a good question I think
chris Christie is trying to get a job
I think he's from Sears right right I
think he's gonna win anything's finally
I'm gonna be a pit boss in Atlantic City
Russia job
I think I don't think he thinks he's
gonna be the vice president because that
would be a little too much of one sort
of testosterone-fueled East Coast right
right kind of alpha male but Attorney
General I think he would love that job
and and I think if he helps Trump Trump
from I mean I'll be thrilled if Trump is
president he doesn't appoint Paula Deen
and Joe the Plumber or judge speedy or
Jersey for Supreme Court earlier did he
love her right
has the success of Donald Trump
diminished the power of money in
politics well that's a good question too
because we saw Jeb Bush drop out and he
certainly had most of the money and
Donald Trump yeah he's isn't Donald
Trump getting money just on the sly I
mean it's not that he's not getting
money he's just not getting as a
traditional way but you know there's a
lot more than his own cash at stake but
I don't think he's a answer to the
referendum more money but Jeb spent
ninety eight million dollars on
advertising and if you're Donald Trump
you're a Content machine right you don't
need to have any advertising because
everybody's covering you
you are the content and Jeb was simply
wrapping his ads around the content of
Trump no I mean it doesn't money doesn't
help you if you're not a good candidate
and Jeb just didn't look like he wanted
it enough yeah I always say it's like a
sports team you know it over the course
of many seasons probably the richard
teams do do better but lots of times I
mean in the World Series last year the
Mets were not one of the richer teams
either with the Royals in the Mets beat
them alright thank you very much
you